die herbstferien beginnen bald und trotz
der korona pandemie möchten einige in
den urlaub wir wollen jetzt darüber
sprechen
auf was sie achten müssen auf die fünf
wichtigsten tipps bei mir im studio ist
jetzt frank ochse unser bild war fox und
verbraucher experte frank die ferien
gehen bald los was muss ich beachten
wenn ich in der korona pandemie
verreisen möchte ja das ist wirklich zum
teil wirklich kompliziert weil wir haben
auch berichtet heute dass diese
verschärfung der quarantäne regeln die
eigentlich möglichst zum ersten oktober
stattfinden sollen da geht es dann um 15
tage frist in quarantäne erst dann ist
ein positiv test möglich dass das
möglicherweise erst am ersten november
passiert und das kann bedeuten dass ich
ganz normal vielleicht anfang oktober in
den urlaub fahren können kommen nach
hause braucht vielleicht kein test zu
machen und aber freunde von medi hat
später nach hause kommen müssen dann
tatsächlich fünf tage in quarantäne also
es ist ziemlich chaotisch noch und wer
man reist muss man ja auch immer so im
flugzeug nachher sowas ausfüllen per
hand mit dem stift da gibt es auch ein
bisschen stress oder genau das sind die
sogenannten ausschlage karten sind
formulare da trage ich ein woher ich
komme auf dem platz ich gesessen habe wo
ich auch zu erreichen bin aber diese
karten müssten digitalisiert wenn damit
man auch nachvollziehen kann
mit welchen menschen hatte dieser
urlauber kontakt und das heißt wenn man
es nur auf schreibt dann müssen halt
menschen da sitzen und sich diese sachen
alle aufschreiben quasi die sollen
digitalisiert werden das verzögert sich
allerdings noch zur zeit ist im gespräch
erst zum ersten november sollen diese
aussteige karten digitalisiert sein und
es gibt aber keine pauschale
reisewarnung ab dem ersten oktober oder
ja das ist wirklich sehr interessant
aber erst natur fällt die pauschale
reisewarnung für länder außerhalb der eu
weg es gibt dann einzelbewertung das
heißt also ich muss genau gucken in
welches land ich vielleicht reisen will
und da gibt es natürlich auch länder wie
zum beispiel australien neuseeland oder
auch die vereinigten arabischen emirate
da wird es keine reisewarnung geben aber
das wird natürlich auch kompliziert und
viel darf das jetzt mit denen kroner
tests ab da gab es ein ordentliches hin
und her mal kostenlos dann doch wieder
nicht was der aktuelle stand der
aktuelle stand ist wenn ich aus einem
risikogebiet komme werde ich ab erster
oktober für meinen krone
test auf jeden fall bezahlen müssen die
kosten liegen bei 60 aber bei besonders
schnellen test auch über 100 euro das
muss man natürlich in sein urlaubsbudget
mit einrechnet weil dadurch der urlaub
natürlich insgesamt auch teurer wird
also kostenlos wird es nicht es sei denn
man kommt wirklich aus einem gebiet
zurück griechenland italien was wirklich
kein risikogebiet ist muss man denn
jetzt abschließt und frank die frage
angst um seinen urlaub haben ja so ein
bisschen scheint es so weil ich weiß
selbst persönlich gar nicht was soll ich
jetzt überhaupt noch buchen klar man
kann sagen griechenland italien macht
man nichts falsch iren sparen sagt in
deutschland ist es doch auch sehr schön
tatsächlich auch meine empfehlung
wirklich urlaub in deutschland aber wer
halt in andere gebiete will muss sich
wirklich dann überlegen auch dort könnte
es natürlich reisewarnung geben oder es
gibt sich schon also mein tipp
tatsächlich um auf nummer sicher zu
gehen tatsächlich die gute alte
pauschalreise buchen gibt es dann eine
reisewarnung dann bekomme ich auf jeden
fall das geld zurück